Hi, welcome to this the first session of
this investment philosophies class. Now,
you're already probably asking what the
heck is an investment philosophy and why
should I have one? So, let me get down
to brass tax right away. An investment
philosophy is a coherent way of thinking
about markets and investors and how you
think you should invest. So to work you
need to understand how markets make
mistakes if they do and how if at all
you can take advantage of those
mistakes.
Now your first reaction when I say
investment philosophy is hey what about
buying low PE stocks. Buying low PE
stocks is not a philosophy it's a
strategy. And I want to draw a contrast
between an investment philosophy and an
investment strategy. An investment
strategy is a way in which you think you
can make money. buying low PE stocks you
think can make you money whether it's
true or not. An investment philosophy is
far bigger. It composes multiple
strategies and you can argue that a
philosophy is essentially what allows
you to come up with new strategies when
old ones stop working.
So let's start this discussion of
investment philosophy. At the heart of
every investment philosophy is a view
about human behavior. The last 40 years
in finance, we've developed this area of
behavioral finance. Behavioral finance,
we contest the rationality assumption
that's at the core of much of economics
and finance. And we bring into play
psychological insights. Connefy who are
at the birth of behavioral finance were
psychologists. They argue that human
beings don't stop being human beings
when they come into markets. And the
quirks in human behavior that are well
observed will show up in markets and
investing in prices. And the heart of a
philosophy is a belief that those human
behaviors cause markets to make mistakes
and per perhaps allow other people to
take advantage of those mistakes.
Now of course along the way we will have
to talk about market efficiency. A
loaded word because the minute you say
it you get push back. I think there are
lots of different ways in which people
think about market efficiency. We'll
come back in a later session and talk
about them. But to me, the essence of a
market efficiency or inefficiency is
that you know you you you think there's
a market mistake you can exploit to make
money. So we can differ in what aspect
or where markets are efficient or
inefficient and that can lead us to very
different ways of thinking about how to
make money on markets. Now once you have
a philosophy in place you can come up
with the investment strategies that flow
out of that philosophy. We will talk
more again about those strategies but
the same philosophy can give rise to
multiple investment strategies.
You might wonder I've lived all my life
as an investor. I don't think I have an
investment philosophy. Why do I need
one? If you don't have an investment
philosophy I will predict that one of
three things or perhaps all three will
happen to you. First, you will become a
magnet for scams. Investing is full of
people offering you Ponzi schemes, get
rich quickly, ways of getting rich
quickly. And if you don't have a core
philosophy, you're going to be drawn to
these scams because even though they
look too good to be true, you your greed
overrides that that caution you you
should bring in. Second, if you don't
have an investment philosophy, all you
have is a strategy and you pick that
strategy because it worked for somebody
else. Even somebody as renowned as
Warren Buffett or Peter Lynch, when that
strategy stops working, you will switch
to a different one. Why? Because
somebody else made money with the other
strategy. That's going to create
switching costs. What are switching
costs? When you shift from strategy to
strategy, you got to sell what's in your
portfolio often and buy new things,
taxes, transactions, cost, both of which
we'll come back and talk about. And if
you pick a philosophy, even unwittingly,
unknowingly, that is not right for you,
that doesn't fit you, it's going to keep
you awake at night. It's going to stress
you out and you are not going to be able
to carry through on that philosophy. So
I'm going to argue that every investor
needs an investment philosophy. To
understand the different kinds of
investment philosophies, I'm going to go
back to the basic investment process.
Every investment process starts with the
person whose money is being invested. So
let's make this simple. Let's suppose
you think about investing your own
money. You are your own client. Here are
the things you got to assess. One is
your willingness to take risk. and we'll
come back and talk about how you can
come up with a more tangible way of
measuring that. Are you risk averse or
risk tolerant? Your time horizon. A
first reaction might be, "Oh, I have a
long time horizon." That's what
everybody says. We look at how real
world concerns can put a crimp on your
time horizon and your tax status. If
you're an individual, you're saying, "I
pay taxes. What's my tax status got to
do with it?" Remember, you pay taxes
differently on different parts of your
portfolio. What am I talking about? If
you have a 401k or a pension fund, it
might be tax exempt. Your regular
savings might be taxable. The money you
invest for your kids tuition might have
a very different tax status. Risk
tolerance, time horizon, and tax status.
Now, once you've assessed the client and
that's you,
then you look at the actual job of
creating a portfolio. And there are
three three parts to it, though they're
not necessarily sequential. First is the
asset allocation part of the process
where you decide how much of your money
to put into stocks, into bonds, into
real assets, into collectibles, into
gold, even crypto, whatever you think
fits in there. And your views on
markets, whether they're overpriced or
underpriced, will come into play. Market
timing, we'll talk about, as well as
your views on macro variables,
inflation, rates, and growth.
Now once you've made your asset
allocation decision, 40% to stocks, 20%
of bonds, 40% into real estate, you get
to the asset selection phase. What does
that mean? You decide to invest 40% of
your money in stocks. Which stocks are
you going to invest in? Which bonds,
which real assets?
There you might use a combination of
public information and you might value
companies and price them. and we'll talk
about the distinction or sometimes
private information things you know that
the rest of the world doesn't
and then what you got to execute once
you've decided the 25 stocks you need in
your portfolio you got to go out and buy
them you're saying what's the big deal
of an online account I'll just get
online and buy them well execution
will become more and more significant
depending on whether your philosophy/st
strategy requires you to trade all the
time how often do to trade, how large
those trades are. Are you planning to
use derivatives markets? If there's a
trade-off between trading speed, and
trading costs, that's got to be factored
in. Asset allocation, security
selection, execution. When you're done,
you have your portfolio. Now, remember,
investing is a pragmatic exercise. You
invest to make money, to earn returns.
You're putting in time and effort. And
if you're honest with yourself, you got
to assess whether it's worth it. What
does that mean? In performance
evaluation, you look at how your
portfolio did given the risk you took
on, whether it earned enough return to
cover the risk. And there you're looking
at both your skills as a market timer
showing up in your asset allocation and
as a stock picker.
Along the way, there are variables
outside of you that come into play. the
trade-off between risk and return.
Whether markets are efficient, if they
make mistakes, where they make mistakes,
the systems you trade in, and models for
risk and return, that's investment
process. If it's your own money, you're
saying, "What if I'm investing other
people's money?" The only part of the
process that's going to be different
then is since it's not your money, it's
somebody else's money. The questions
about risk tolerance and time horizon
and tax status has to be about that
person. It's always the person whose
money that's being invested that should
drive your choices rather than your own.
That investment process is going to
allow us to think about different kinds
of investment philosophies. In
particular, there are four
categorizations I'm going to make on
investment philosophies. The first is do
you want to be an investor or do you
want to be a trader? You're saying
what's the big deal? What's the
difference? When you invest, you
estimate the value of something, and you
buy if the price is less, and you pray
and hope that they converge. In trading,
you buy at a low price, you sell at a
higher price. You really don't care.
It's not deep. You're not wondering why
it happened. You just want to make that
difference. Investing versus trading.
We'll come back and talk about the
contrast. At this stage, you're saying,
"I'm an investor. I don't want to be a
trader." Don't be so quick to judge.
Your investment philosophy can be about
market timing. You think your skills are
in looking at overall markets, stock
markets, bond markets or within stock
markets, different geographies and
calling direction and betting on the
direction through your asset allocation
decision. Or you might believe you're
better at stock picking. You're not good
at market timing. Or you might be one of
those people who thinks you're good at
both.
Activist versus passive investing. Not
active versus passive. That's a
different contrast. Activist versus
passive investing. In passive investing,
you buy something and then you go back
to do living the rest of your life
hoping that whatever your investment
went goes up. That's what we often do
when we buy shares in publicly traded
companies. In passive investing, your
act is just investing and then letting
karma play out. In activist investing,
you invest in something and then you
take a role in how what you've invested
in is run. Activist investing obviously
requires far more in resources than
passive investing. We'll talk about that
contrast. And finally, as a subtext here
to all these choices, some investment
philosophies can be short-term, others
can be long-term. There's nothing
inherently good or bad about either.
They're just different. Now, with that
categorization, let's talk about
contradictory versus complimentary
philosophies. Now sometimes you'll have
investors who are both as I said market
time is and stock pickers. That's
perfectly okay. They can coexist. You
can have different investment
philosophies coexisting with the same
investor. You might believe that markets
are slow to learn from it information.
Therefore, you might be a market timer
who trades on price momentum. But at the
same time, you can have market times or
contrarians. In other words, in the same
market, you can have people with very
different and contradictive views.
In stock selection, you get people who
use fundamentals, people who use charts,
people who look at pricing momentum,
again coexisting in the same market.
These contradictory philosophies can
sometimes come from different views of
the market, but they can also come from
different time horizon, views on risk,
tax statuses.
Put simply, nobody here has a monopoly
on the right philosophy. You can have
different philosophies and they can all
strangely make money at different points
in time.
Ultimately, this is an exercise in being
pragmatic. There are no pure investment
philosophies, good versus bad. This is
about making money.
So, let me go back and put investment
philosophies in context using those
three steps in the portfolio building
process. Your investment philosophy,
it's a market timing philosophy will
show up primarily in the asset
allocation part. How much money you
allocate to stocks, to bonds, to real
estate. If you're a stock picker, it's
going to show up primarily in the stock
selection part. Whether you're a
chartist, a value investor, a growth
investor.
If on the other hand, you're neither an
asset allocation or a stock picker, your
investment philosophy might be finding
small market mistakes and locking in
your profits.
You might just be a trader. You might be
an information trader or an
arbitrage-based trader.
We'll talk about all of these different
philosophies and they will play out in
different parts of the portfolio
process.
So, as we embark on this journey,
there are the three steps I would like
to take you through. I'm going to spend
the first few sessions acquiring what I
call the tools of the trade. Being able
to understand risk and incorporating
that risk into your decision- making.
Understanding the difference between
value and price and how to value
companies. Understanding the language of
business which is accounting and
understanding the frictions and the
costs of trading. What is the true cost
of trading? What are the reasons you
might trade quickly and what are the
costs you might bear? So, we'll spend
the first few sessions because without
those tools for the trade, we can fall
into traps.
Second step and this is part of a
process that starts now and will you can
continue for the rest of your investing
life is to develop a point of view about
how markets work and where they might
break down.
We'll start on that discussion but the
but the point I would like to make is
the discussion will not be over when
this class is over. You would your views
on markets will continue to evolve as
you observe what happens in markets and
as they evolve your philosophy might
change and then find the philosophy that
provides the best fit for you. Let me
emphasize again the philosophy that's
right for you is the one that best fits
you. The reason I emphasize that walk
into any bookstore and you walk to the
investing section you're going to see
books on great investors. Warren Buffett
alone probably has a a thousand books
written about him. And you pick up the
book and you read that book and you say,
"I want to be like Warren Buffett. I
want to be like Peter Lynch. I want to
be like George Soros.
I want to be like Jim Simon." That's
nice. They had philosophies. They were
successful investors but none of their
philosophies might work for you because
your the philosophy that's right for you
fits you in terms of your risk aversion
in terms of how much you have to invest
in terms of your time arise and your tax
status and you got to find that
philosophy. So let's talk a little bit
about those factors and how they will
play out.
Let's start with the assertion and I
think this is an assertion that at least
in the investing space investors are for
the most part risk averse. What does
that mean? They don't like to take risk.
And to induce them to take risk, you got
to offer them a higher return. And if
you want a higher expected return, you
got to be willing to live with risk.
Now, of course, that opens the door to
what is risk? How do we measure it? How
do we come up with a quantitative
measure? And do those risk and return
models work in terms of delivering
results
in terms of portfolio size? How much
money you have to invest will clearly
play an impact will have an impact and
what investment philosophy you adopt.
You know now you might say well if I
have a lot of money do I start with an
advantage? Not necessarily because for
some strategies you might need less
funds to succeed. It's true. If you want
to be an activist value investor, we try
to change the way companies run. You you
can't do that with a $100,000 or $10,000
in your portfolio. But there might be
niche strategies.
We're trying to take advantage of a
small mistake in the market that's a
small one where you're better off having
less to invest than more because a
hundred billion dollars directed at that
mistake can very quickly wipe out your
returns. So your portfolio size can
affect your philosophy choice and time
arise. As I said, most people when
they're asked what their time horizon is
will almost automatically say, "I have a
long time horizon." Because they've been
taught that that's the right thing to
say. But do you really control your time
horizon? Some of your time horizon comes
from who you are as a person. Some of us
are naturally more patient than others.
And if you're more patient than others,
you have a longer time horizon. You're
born with that. You can't change that.
The other is the world imposes
constraints on you. You're 74 years old.
Your time horizon is getting shorter
than when you were 24 years old. Age
matters. Your health matters. Whether
your kids have to go to college matters
because you need the cash. So your need
for cash can make your long time horizon
to much shorter one. So rather than just
say long time horizon, look inward.
at what kind of time horizon you can
afford to have. Generally, the longer
the time horizon you have, the greater
the amount of your portfolio you can put
into risky investments. Why? Because
risky investments get upside, they also
get downside. Downside can be pretty
substantial. And if you have downside,
you need time to recover. So think about
your risk aversion, how much money you
have to invest in your time horizon, but
also think about your tax status. It's
going to state the obvious. You get to
spend only the returns you're left over
after paying taxes. So, a portfolio
that's right for somebody who's tax
exempt might not be right for you. And
even within your portfolio, some of your
money might be tax exempt. As I said in
a pension fund, others might not. And
along the way, you got to work in the
differential treatment of income,
capital gains versus dividends,
different portions of your savings, and
changing tax rates across time.
You can see choice of an investment
philosophy requires being inward looking
and making that judgment.
So what what is the the bottom line I
hope you get out of this session? Every
investor needs an investment philosophy
and you have to have beliefs about
markets and how they work. Which means
that this is not something that you can
just read up. You got to get you you got
to observe what happens in markets.
Think about it and incorporate that into
your thinking.
As you invest, you will learn what makes
you comfortable and what makes you
uncomfortable. And rather than pushing
the uncomfortable things away, look
deeper at them because they might help
you fine-tune the right philosophy. So
at the risk of restating what I've said
before, there is no one best in
investment philosophy for all investors,
but there's one that's best for you
given who you are as a person. In this
class, my objective is to give you a
menu of investment philosophies without
putting in my biases too much into the
process and let you pick what's right
for you. And I hope you succeed.
Thank you very much for listening.